the xenophobic nationalist right loves
to talk about how none of these
immigrants can assimilate in the United
States they bring their own language
they bring their own culture they bring
their own skin color well okay maybe
that last one there at least not
supposed to say out loud anyway the
Nationalists love to talk about how
immigrants from Latin America or the
Middle East or Asia basically from
anywhere other than Europe
they just can't assimilate here or they
choose not to or they don't have the
cognitive capacity to do it they can't
successfully integrate themselves into
the American milieu and culture so say
than the conservative nationalist I want
to flip this around I want to make the
case that it's the conservative
nationalists who are unable to
assimilate to the reality of 20:19
United States of America there's a
really good article on reason.com
about this the way the argument usually
goes is people come here from other
countries they change the fabric of the
country they make it something else
something other than what we believe it
is supposed to be and next thing you
know we'll be living under Sharia law or
Spanish will be the national language of
the United States or whatever which is a
very popular but also completely bogus
slippery slope argument that the
conservative nationalists just love to
make the reality is that it is them it's
the conservative nationalists who are
unable to assimilate to the reality of
life in the USA in 2019 the United
States was founded on principles that
these extremist conservative nationalist
enclaves simply cannot accept or adapt
to imagine a community that rallies
around the Confederate flag the opposite
of what the United States stands for and
represents those groups that look at the
Confederacy that fought for slavery in
the Civil War they look at that era as
the golden era they're not assimilated
to the modern reality of the United
States
they don't fit here that's the reality
the immigrant from Guatemala who comes
to New York City and goes to school
while working in a restaurant
is far more assimilated to the ideals
and values of the United States than
conservative nationalists who in their
minds are still living in the 1800's of
the United States it's not even a close
call like that there's not even a debate
to be had about who is actually
assimilated here in the United States
there's this revival of a sort of
nationalist conservative rural white
identity and you don't have to check
every single one of those boxes to be
part of it
that is simply unassimilated to the
reality of the 2019 united states of
america they do not fit here their
culture conservative nationalist culture
runs counter to that of the United
States at large now yes I understand
that there are parts of the country
where it's not obvious that it runs
counter but the truth is that their
culture runs counter to that of the
United States their language including
the terms that they use and how they
talk about issues runs counter to the
way that the United States of America is
increasingly talking about issues their
views certainly run counter to the
foundational views and values of the
United States why is it that they can't
accept that they live in the United
States and accept the principles on
which the country was founded and
assimilate and get in line they say that
that's what the immigrants are supposed
to do I say that's what they should do
assimilate instead of talking about
kicking people out assimilate instead of
talking about building walls or using
racial slurs and in fact there's
actually an irony much of the
Confederacy simply didn't want to be
part of the United States and based on
their total lack of assimilation in the
modern day maybe they still don't want
to be part of what the United States
actually is consider that immigrants
value education in modern-day 20:19 USA
much more than these conservative
nationalists who see it instead is some
form of liberal indoctrination for those
fancy schmancy liberals the view of the
immigrant on education is by and large
far more assimilated to the values of
the United States than the view of
education that the conservative
nationalists hold
you have in this coalition conservative
nationalist coalition a bitter and angry
and entitled group of people that is
just refusing to accept the country not
for what they fear it is becoming but
for what it actually is and has always
been a melting pot I know it's cliche
but it's a melting pot that they want to
be the sole beneficiaries of not people
that look different from them or that
have different cultural backgrounds or
different views about education quite
frankly and my message to them is if
they can't assimilate what are they
doing what are they planning to do
because the answer to that question may
actually be extraordinarily disturbing
and dystopian Donald Trump said if you
don't like it leave it's interesting
that it's not being applied to the
conservative nationalists who
increasingly are completely
unassimilated here in the United States
of America let me know what you think I
know many of you will